اعتقد ان علينا ان نتقدم نحو الامام وفي
نهايه المطاف الحرب في اوكرانيا ان كانت
فيها نقطه ايجابيه فهي انها دفعت البلدان
الاوروبيه الى التفكير حتى وان كانت تعيش
بسلام ان عليها الاستعداد لاي اعتداء
محتمل الدول الاوروبيه التي كانت في
غالبيتها لا تنفقوا الا مبالغ محدوده جدا
على الدفاع باتت اليوم تبذل جهدا كبيرا من
اجل زياده امكاناتها العسكريه ماذا ذكرته
في ندوه قبل ايام ان الاوكرانيين من دون
دعم المعدات الاوروبيه والامريكيه لم
استطاعوا ان يصمدوا في وجه الجيش الروسي
ولو توافرت المعدات من دون وجود عزيمه
لبنانيين على الصمود لما كانت المعدات
تنفع في شيء على القاره الاوروبيه اليوم
ان تستخلص العبر كلها واعتقد انه بات من
الضروري وعلى غرار ما تقوم به دول عده
القيام بتعزيز وسائل الدفاع وايجاد اليه
لاستخدام المعدات المشتركه كما انتجنا
طائره ام 400 لتزويد الوقود ومروحيه النمر
ومروحيه ان ايج 90 وهذا يدفعنا الى بذل
مزيدا من التعاون في المجال الصناعي في
تلك الندوه ذكرت هيئات الاركان في جيوش
والوزراء انه علينا زياده الانفاق ولكن
ليس لشراء المعادلات العسكريه من
الامريكيين بحيث نصبح معتمدين عليها علينا
ان نطور صناعاتنا العسكريه لتلبيه حاجاتنا
ولكي تساعدنا على تجهيز جيوش اخرى انا
اعتقد بضروره ايجاد دفاع اوروبيا وليس
جيشا اوروبيا قبل 30 او 40 عاما دفاعا
اوروبيا يمكن تشكيله في الاشهر المقبله
وليس اوروبيا انا فكرت في هذا الامر عندما
كنت وزيره للدفاع وشكلنا مجموعات من وحدات
خاصه يمكنها ان تتدخل سريعا قمنا بمناورات
تدريب مشتركه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وانشانا
مصانع مشتركه وانشطه مشتركه من خلال فرقه
او شيئا من هذا القبيل يجب تعزيز القدرات
هذا بالامكان تحقيقه بسرعه نسبيا وهذا
يتيح لاوروبا ان يكون لديها دبلوماسيه
فاعله اعتقد انه لا توجد دبلوماسيه من دون
نفاع من دون ذلك نبقى في اطار الكلام نعلن
عن نوايا حسنا ولكن ان لم يكن لدينا مثلا
الامكانات للدفاع عن حقوق الانسان او
لمساعده بلد صديق لدفاع عن سيادته من خلال
امكاناتنا وباستخدام قوتنا ذاتيه انا ذاك
هذا الامر لن يكون مفيدا علينا ان نكون
قادرين على ان ندعم فعليا الدفاع وتاليا
ان ادعو الى تحقيق ذلك ويمكننا ان نتقدم
في هذا المجال